battlefield one may take players back to
nineteen eighteen but there was one to
call a duty game in development that
would take players much further back
GamesRadar reports that call of duty
roman wars were set in ancient rome and
featured first-person sword combat i'm
lucy and welcome to your at tu brute a
game spot news updates a demo for the
lost call of duty game apparently
impressed Activision and was even seen
by CEO bobby kotick however games radar
reports that a mixture of studio
stubbornness and fears of over
saturating the brand killed the Roman
Wars chances at life gamesradar source
who chose to go by Paul emmis says
Skylanders developer Vicarious Visions
created the prototype which was
eventually turned into Roman Wars by
members who left the team it was pitched
to ubisoft which explains the company
flags in the gameplay footage apparently
Roman Wars was born out of a test to see
what Activision studios could create
with the call of duty named Roman Wars
was built from the foundation of marvel
ultimate alliance 2 and utilized both
first and third person perspectives the
first person view was apparently similar
to 2005 s condemned criminal origins
while the third person was very gears of
war style ulemas told gamesradar that
you play as several different characters
from a lowly grunt to Julius Caesar
himself it would have strive toward
accuracy with its battles keeping close
to Caesars real-life conquests you can
read more about the inner workings on
call of duty Roman wars over on
GamesRadar the link is on screen now
would you have played Roman wars or do
you prefer the more modern setting for
your call of duty's let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games for more
on call of duty make sure you keep it
gamespot